>> Sean: IN TIME FOR MORE ON
WHAT WE CALLED SELECTIVE MORAL
OUTRAGE ON THIS PROGRAM.
WE BRING IN JUANITA BRODERICK
TOLD THE STORY ABOUT
BILL CLINTON AND RATE BACK IN
THE 70s.
ALSO WITH US, THE AUTHOR OF THE
NUMBER ONE BEST SELLER,
GREGG JARRETT.
I DID THE SECOND INTERVIEW WITH
YOU, AND EVEN THROUGH THIS LAST
ELECTION, A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WE
ARE HEARING FROM NOW, THEY WERE
SILENT.
THEY NEVER WANTED -- THEY DIDN'T
WANT AN FBI INVESTIGATION FOR
YOU THAT I REMEMBER.
>> OH, NO, SENATOR FEINSTEIN,
SENATOR DURBIN AND
SENATOR SCHUMER WANTED NOTHING
TO DO WITH MY CASE.
ALL DEMOCRATS REFUSED TO READ MY
DEPOSITION WITH THE INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL.
>> Sean: THEY NEVER ONCE
REACHED OUT TO YOU?
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE STILL THERE,
THE ONES ACTING, YOU KNOW, THE
ONES THAT ARE SO SUPPORTIVE OF
THE ALLEGATIONS?
>> NO THEY NEVER REACHED OUT TO
ME.
>> Sean: WHEN THIS HAPPENED TO
YOU, BECAUSE I KNOW BECAUSE I'VE
INTERVIEWED IT, IT WAS
30 MINUTES LATER YOU TOLD THE
WOMAN YOU ARE WITH AND YOUR LIP
WAS THREE TIMES ITS NORMAL SIZE?
>> RIGHT, AND BLEEDING.
THE WOMAN CAME BACK TO THE ROOM
AND FOUND ME WHEN I DIDN'T SHOW
UP FOR THE SEMINAR AND OF
COURSE, I TOLD HER IMMEDIATELY,
LOOK AT THE CONDITION I WAS IN.
MY CLOTHES WERE TORN, MY LIP WAS
HUGE, AND I WAS DEVASTATED.
>> Sean: AND AFRAID OF.
>> OH GOODNESS, YES.
>> Sean: AND NOBODY -- THE
DEMOCRATS, THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
WERE ACTING SO INDIGNANT,
NOTHING?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
>> Sean: GREGG JARRETT, FROM A
LEGAL STANDPOINT, THE FBI HAS
ALSO SAID THAT THIS IS NOT
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION.
WE PLAYED JOE BIDEN.
THIS WAS A TALKING POINT FOR
DELAY TODAY, WASN'T IT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
BY LAW THE FBI IS NOT ALLOWED TO
INVESTIGATE A NONFEDERAL CRIME.
THEY CAN ONLY DO BACKGROUND
CHECKS, AND AS BIDEN POINTED
OUT, THEY SIMPLY TAKE WITNESS
STATEMENTS, THEY DON'T JUDGE
GUILT OR INNOCENCE OR THE
CREDIBILITY OF PARTICULAR
WITNESSES.
SO IT WAS AN UTTER CANARD OVER
AND OVER AGAIN CALL FOR
CAVANAUGH TO ASK FOR AN FBI
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: JUANITA, YOU WERE
HERE TODAY AND EVEN DURING 2016,
YOU FELT COMPELLED TO SPEAK UP
ABOUT THE DOUBLE STANDARD.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE
DEMOCRATS THAT, CLEARLY, THIS IS
ABOUT POLITICS AND NOT ABOUT
WHAT'S RIGHT?
>> WELL, I CLEARLY THINK IF
SENATOR FEINSTEIN AND
SENATOR DURBIN HAD KNOWN THAT I
WAS OUTSIDE, I THINK THEY SHOULD
HAVE WALKED OUT AND APOLOGIZE TO
ME FOR WHAT THEY DID TO ME IN
1999, COMPLETELY TURNING THEIR
BACKS ON ME.
>> Sean: AND KATHLEEN AND
PAULA AND JENNIFER, WHO WAS
CALLED A LIAR.
>> EXACTLY, YES.